[Music]
after days of heavy fighting dozens of
soldiers on motorbikes came rushing away
from the front line into the eastern
city of Goma in Democratic Republic of
conge
they've been battling fighters of M23
widely understood to be a proxy of
neighboring Rwanda although Rwanda
denies it
it caused panic
thousands of people thought M23 had
reached the edge of the city
I come from kabumba I ran away from the
M23 and got to Kanya Regina camp on
Saturday then I heard gunfire and people
said M23 has arrived that's why we
decided to carry our belongings and run
away
we are asking for our soldiers to be
helped with reinforcements because there
are too few soldiers to defend the whole
province
Congo's Army said a group of soldiers
had panicked unnecessarily While others
continued fighting
people here are scared of M23 the rebel
group took the city of Gomer in 2012
also with Rwandan backing the following
year it withdrew and then it was
defeated by Congo's Armed Forces it
resumed its Rebellion a year ago to
people here appearing the m23s fighters
might take the city of Goma once again
Congo's Army's fighting M23 on three
front including with Attack Helicopters
it says n23 has sophisticated weapons
from Rwanda
last time Congo eventually won the war
with international support this time the
government's relations with the UN
peacekeepers have deteriorated and it
doesn't have much help
I can assure you our armed forces are
doing well on the battlefield and are so
far containing the Enemy at the town of
kibumba big
boom was about 20 kilometers north of
Goma as some soldiers fled others were
sent forward
the people here had already fled their
homes and were in camps when the Panic
set in
conflicts involving Rwanda and Uganda
have been displacing people here for
decades there's no sign they'll be left
in peace anytime soon
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera Gomer Democratic
Republic of Congo